what's going on guys so you may notice
looks like I'm in some kind of generic
spaceship that's because my mom needed
our other set for her book club meeting
they're reading gone girl again this
week hi mom so we got our first peek at
Fantastic Four we're gonna break it down
in depth and debate it coming up this
weekend in movie fights but right now
we're gonna give you 10 big reveals from
the Fantastic Four trailer number one
let's get this out of the way right now
it's not a found footage movie no I had
no idea that this thought was going
around but I read online that a lot of
people thought that this might be a
found footage movie a lot of people were
saying oh well Josh Trank's other movie
Chronicle was a superhero movie that was
found footage that also starred Michael
B Jordan so this has to be exactly the
same no that's not the way life works
not everything everyone does is exactly
the same as the last thing it's not like
every movie that Eli Roth makes is going
to be torture porn bad example but you
know what I mean
number two this ain't your grandpappy's
Fantastic Four rumors have been swirling
for months that these characters would
not be based on the original Stan Lee
Jack Kirby creations but rather drawn
from the Marvel Ultimate Universe which
was created in 2000 and features
re-imaginings of classic Marvel
characters and some of the biggest
changes made were to the Fantastic Four
with a revamped origin story and a much
younger team this trailer definitely
confirms that this version will be the
basis of a complete franchise reboot
even the mysterious device in the
trailers money shot matches a similar
one in the ultimate Fantastic Four
comics number three more kids that's
right it wouldn't be a modern superhero
movie without getting to see our
powerful superheroes as sweet little
children and we get to see Reed Richards
looking like he's laying the groundwork
for whatever's gonna happen in the
future to turn his friends into weirdos
and monsters great work kid you really
nailed it a plus number four it's time
to go negative I'm talking about the
negative zone the ultimate Fantastic
Four origin story did away with the
Hokey cosmic rays and instead gave the
team their powers from the negative zone
dying antimatter universe that's why the
team looks distinctly earthbound there
are no cosmic moon shots in this
Fantastic Four it's all negative energy
number five ultimate Doctor Doom is in
the house so it appears that there are
more than four people entering those
mystery pods in the trailer which seems
to tell us that Doctor Doom is going to
be getting his powers from the negative
zone now old do me he didn't fare that
well on this version gaining not only
awesome powers but a horribly disfigured
it's pretty gross appearance with claws
and hooves kind of like if you imagine
Iron Man mating with a scent or and this
is their baby that also happens to be a
homicidal maniac number six Doctor Doom
is going to his house one
much-talked-about shot from the trailer
appears to highlight a particular
European country on a map that Sue Storm
is looking at that shot also provides an
IP address that takes you to various
wiki pages for Latveria the home of the
Fantastic Four is greatest enemy Doctor
Doom now this could be setting up a much
bigger role in the movie for doctor
dooms home country or it could just be
giving the same obligatory lip service
that they gave it in the other old
crummy fantastic four movies could you
just do us a favor don't us over on
Latveria number seven Nerdist was right
a few days ago Nerdist released some
sketches that were based on descriptions
of the new suits and based on the
trailers they were right these suits are
containment suits that will help them
harness and channel their newfound
powers so they're not blue spandex but
on the bright side they're not blue
spandex number eight trailers still
don't know how to use letters and
numbers correctly if I had never heard
of the Fantastic Four and let's say I
had no idea that there was a new
Fantastic Four movie coming out I'd
think that the name of this movie was
fantastic that's not a thing stop it and
speaking of things that are overused in
trailers number nine all superhero movie
trailers are the same now this trailer
along with Ant Man Man of Steel and many
others confirm that all you need to
tease a new
superhero franchises mixed together sad
piano music even sadder voiceover what's
the last thing you remember what if a
child aspired to something greater this
is your chance how did we get this far
second unit shots of landscapes shots of
people looking at each other and then
maybe tease the superhero for a second
we're just churning out generic crap
trailers and finally perhaps the most
important thing that we learned is that
the thing is a pervert dude's got no
pants giant rock monsters standing there
with his pebble dangling in the wind hey
thing put your thing away
I barely tolerated it from dr. Manhattan
and you know what I'm not gonna take it
from you so guys what did you think
about the Fantastic Four trailer are you
excited about the movie leave us an
answer in the comments section below
best answer we're gonna send you screen
junkies t-shirt also if you want to hear
more passionate debates about the
Fantastic Four trailer and various other
awesome topics tune in this weekend
click on screen junkies movie fights
where we will dough add it thanks again
for watching I'm Hal redneck hit me up
on Twitter bye bye fellow nominee and
fellow Hulk Mark Ruffalo was in the
super sweet eighties acne commercial
check it out you can run but you can't
hide you zap one pimple another one
appears you need to
three pimples you have fight once you
don't double shap
Oh smash acne